welcome to this video playing uncle yo
doc from Germany very high rated he
doesn't have a name in there but it's
very high rating and I'm not quite sure
uncle ruckus I need to google that if
there's uncle obviously is the uncle and
what what am I playing here actually I
wanted to play it play this Kalashnikov
okay then let's go for the shrek Nick
off I have an outline here but should be
six that I played years ago yeah I need
to google that maybe that's some some
some character from from from a movie or
a book or something your dog is not a
regular kind of name on um okay so this
is this is the idea taking on d6 is very
risky now though I forgot what's the
best replies it is risky this much I
know Knight b6 yeah is the normal move
and now who could be eight
95 quindi eight this is a line that i
have had studied years ago to have some
alternative and the sicilian that it is
that is not not to try explored I
vaguely remember that that should be
five and then g 6 + f5 is the way to
play yeah it is interesting the
interesting positional feature about
this position of course of the Knights
they are so nicely positioned at least
from from an optical point of view and
they look nice on b6 and arrive but it's
also clear what they're doing they're
not attacking much and see he's trying
to regroup so I'm going for this f5
counter play as usual if he goes night
III I just oops oops while thinking
about some positional features he just
took this pawn wow I did see that coming
obviously hmm
hmm Gwen so
hmm so some way to at least get some
play out of this may be put with the
threat dat too I can I can get something
here this pin is a bit awkward
yeah he's just grabbing all kinds of
stuff that I'm that I'm obviously
leaving hanging but this is maybe this
move I didn't see that beforehand but I
can take p 7 i'm not seeing much in this
game so
I can just take and play Bishop c4 it's
two pawns right yeah it's two points for
zip and pip I have absolutely no
compensation can try to get a bishop to
see 30
yeah I know you're going to play six
even yeah it's just it's just busted
yeah it's no use c'mon black resigns
yeah 96 yeah it's not even good of the
97 I'm I'm fine the comp com possess at
least I'll be five with the black
advantage be five they are sort of
trapping the night intending what King
g7 and we should be seven now okay no
one's going to see that yeah I just need
to play King age eight or something and
get rid of this stupid trick and then
it's just a normal position just King a
jade or something so after the taking
here so I didn't what I didn't see any
of the good moves and I took so and now
Queen c7 probably yeah didn't I didn't
see this one and this I probably didn't
see before wine but it said it wasn't it
wasn't the problem white is just winning
him yeah good game by him not much what
you can watch you can save I mean okay
it's just the theoretical thing that
this is kind of move like 97 is actually
good for black or b-five who is going to
see that in a blitz game p 5 yeah
actually considered briefly but I
thought that maybe I can do something
with the pin but I overlooked Misha
basics yeah this isn't it just takes
away all the squares yeah that's no way
I'm going to do that alright thanks for
watching